VQEアルゴリズムの成功は、
最初に選ぶ状態と circuit に
大きく依存します。
Victoria Lipinskaです。この動画では
それらの設計における選択肢を
探っていきます。
VQEの量子部分における
各実行の要素を
詳しく見ていきましょう。
まず参照状態から始めます。
これは初期状態とも呼ばれます。
参照状態をパラメータ化された circuit、
いわゆる変分形式に
初期パラメータの選択とともに通します。
そして、ハミルトニアンの基底で
状態を測定し、
circuit を通した後に
期待値を得ます。それでは
各要素を順に見ていきましょう。
まず参照状態からです。
参照状態の典型的な選択は
ゼロ状態です。
これは量子コンピュータが
すでに初期化されている状態です。
量子化学の問題では、
いわゆるHartree-Fock状態を
使うこともできます。
これはHartree-Fock法の
結果です。
簡単に言えば、Hartree-Fock理論は
参照状態を構築するための
簡単な方法を提供し、量子系の
基底状態を近似します。
状態空間内の回転を見つけ、
基底状態エネルギーを最小化します。
最後に、参照状態は
非常に問題に特化したものにもでき、
カスタム状態を
選ぶこともできます。
システムの性質がわかっている場合、
例えば対称性や
状態における特定の電子数など、
それを利用して
VQEアルゴリズムの
収束を改善できます。
良い参照状態を選ぶことは
収束にとって重要です。
基底状態に近い参照状態は、
問題の収束をより簡単に
速くすることができます。
同様に重要なのが、
変分形式に入力する
初期パラメータ値の選択です。
そのため、参照状態と
初期パラメータによっては、
速く収束する場合も、遅く収束する場合も、
まったく収束しない場合もあります。
このグラフを見てみましょう。
可視化のために、
パラメータ空間にパラメータが
1つだけあると想像しましょう。
非常に良い参照状態であれば、
最終的な基底状態の
非常に近くから始められ、
収束は速くなります。
一方、基底状態から非常に
遠い位置から始めると、
参照状態aの場合、
高いエネルギー障壁を
越える必要があり、非常に遅い収束か
まったく収束しない結果になります。
これについては、このコースの
古典最適化モジュールで
さらに詳しく議論します。
次に、参照状態に作用する
パラメータ化された circuit、
つまり変分形式を見てみましょう。
この circuit、すなわちU(θ)が
参照状態に作用すると、
試行状態と呼ばれるものが生成されます。
ψ(θ)、またはアンザッツとも
呼ばれます。
このアンザッツ状態を適切な基底で
測定し、
エネルギーの期待値を
得ます。
ここで議論している変分形式は
化学に基づいたものです。
ただし、量子機械学習や
その他の短期アルゴリズム、例えば
量子近似最適化アルゴリズムに
触発されたものもあることを覚えておいてください。
化学アンザッツの
一般的な選択について議論しましょう。
ユニタリ結合クラスター、つまりUCC
は最初のVQE論文で
提案された手法であり、
量子化学の問題で
一般的に使われています。
通常、量子状態を
パラメータ化する際、
指数関数的に多くの
パラメータを扱います。
しかし、準備 circuit を効率的にするには、
多項式個の演算、
したがって多項式個の
パラメータが必要です。
UCCはそのような circuit で
試行状態を準備する方法の一例であり、
結合クラスター法から
導かれています。
これは量子化学における
ゴールドスタンダードです。
最も一般的な選択は、
ユニタリ結合クラスター
単一・二重励起アンザッツ、
略してUCCSDです。
UCCSDは問題の特定の電子配置に
基づいているため、
システムを適切に反映する
参照状態が必要です。
これがHartree-Fock状態です。
UCCSDアンザッツは通常、
基底状態の良い近似を与えます。
なぜなら、分子中の単一および二重
電子励起を捉えるからです。
UCCSDのパラメータ数は
スピン軌道の数に対して
二次的にスケールします。
UCCSDは問題に非常に
よく適合させることができますが、
残念ながら二次スケーリングでも
非常に深い circuit になり、
現在の量子コンピュータには
困難です。
そのため、IBM研究者はより
ヒューリスティックなアプローチを提案しました。
変分形式を基盤となるハードウェアに
合わせることで、
効率的に実行可能な circuit が
得られます。
つまり、試行状態は量子 gate で
パラメータ化され、
利用可能な物理デバイスに
適合されます。
これはハードウェアに優しい
非常にヒューリスティックなアプローチです。
これらの例を基に、
変分形式を表現するための
可能性のスペクトルを
見てみましょう。
これらの多くは
すでに Qiskit に実装されていますので、
ぜひご自身で試してみてください。
解こうとしている問題に
最も適したものを見つけてください。
グラフを見ると、一方には非常に
ヒューリスティックな
変分形式があります。
問題の特異性は低いですが、
実際のハードウェアで実装できるように
設計されています。
また、非常に表現力が高く、
多くの量子状態を
表現できるという意味です。
ただし、古典最適化の後の段階で
発生する可能性がある問題は、
いわゆるバレンプラトーです。
次のモジュールで議論します。
他方では、非常に問題に特化した
ユニタリ結合クラスターがあり、
古典化学では優れていますが、
circuit の深さが大きいため、
量子ハードウェアでの実装が困難です。
一般的に、計算は次の場合に
より成功しやすくなります。
まず、基底状態に近い
アンザッツ状態を作る
参照状態と初期パラメータセットを
選ぶこと。
次に、不必要なパラメータを
避けること。
これらは見返りなく
circuit の深さを増やすか、
より大きなパラメータ空間を作り、
古典最適化における
プラトーにつながります。
どのパラメータが必要かは
問題に特有の質問であり、
慎重な検討が必要です。
ここで主役の
ハミルトニアンがこの中で
どこに隠れているか話しましょう。
前のセクションで学んだように、
qubit マッピング後の
ハミルトニアンはパウリ演算子の
重み付き文字列の和として表されます。
最終的には、変分形式によって
生成されたアンザッツ状態での
ハミルトニアンの期待値を評価したいのです。
幸い、量子力学は
線形性を持っており、
これを利用して
期待値を求めます。
仕組みはこうです。
ハミルトニアンはパウリの
重み付き和であることがわかっています。
線形性により、和の期待値は
各パウリ文字列の
期待値の和に等しくなります。
すばらしいことに、ご存知のように
パウリ基底での測定は
標準測定基底の回転と
同じくらい簡単です。
この巨大なハミルトニアンの
期待値を和として測定する代わりに、
まず個々の項の期待値を評価し、
対応する重みで
最後に合計します。
これが多くの資料で
アンザッツの後に単一 qubit 回転のみが
見られる理由です。
これが circuit の各実行で
ハミルトニアンを実装するものです。
次の動画では、
古典最適化ステップで
何が起こるかを探ります。
それではまたお会いしましょう。